Michael mandelbaum author of the ideas
that conquered the world why did you
write this book and who did you write it
for the purpose of this book is to
provide a framework for understanding
all the international issues of the 21st
century from globalization to terrorism
from Chinese succession politics to
Latin American economic crises it's a
framework a context we had such a thing
during the Cold War and it was the cold
war itself almost everything that
happened in the second half of the 20th
century either emanated from or could be
related to the great conflict between
the United States and the Soviet Union
and then the Cold War ended and there
was a conceptual vacuum and what I
wanted to do in this book is provide a
substitute for the Cold War as a
framework as a frame of reference and
that frame of reference is as I say in
the book the dominance of three great
ideas peace democracy and free markets
now when I say dominance I don't mean
that these ideas are universal clearly
they're not the world is not fully
democratic and it's certainly not
entirely peaceful what I mean by the
dominance of these three great ideas as
the contacts for everything that's
happening in the 21st century is that
for the first time since the second half
of the 18th century when they were first
invented they have no serious rivals as
models for social and political
organization in the 20th century they
were challenged by communism and fascism
but with the defeat of those two great
ideologies these three great ideas stand
unchallenged as models I illustrate
their status by a story I tell in the
book about a French architect who was
asked where in Paris he would most like
to live he replied the Eiffel Tower on
the grounds that that was the only place
in the city where he wouldn't have to
look at it well peace democracy and free
markets are the Eiffel Tower in the 21st
century
you may not like them and obviously
there are people who violently dislike
them but you have to come to terms with
them there are no alternatives there are
no other models and that is a portent
and powerful fact of our times what have
you done in your life that got you to
this point where you can write a book
like this well this book took me when
I'm asked how long did it take to write
this book I say the truest answer is my
entire life up to the point at which i
finished it because this book is the
product of what is now quite a long
period of reading writing reflection and
rumination my academic career really had
two periods before this I started off
writing about nuclear weapons and I
wrote three books about nuclear weapons
issues the nuclear question the United
States and nuclear weapons 1946 276
published by Cambridge University Press
the nuclear revolution published also by
Cambridge University Press and then the
nuclear future published by Cornell
press and one day I was speaking with a
friend and colleague in severe and Ayala
in him and in Soviet ologist he said
Michael you think the great problem in
the world is the bomb the great problem
is not the bomb it's the Russians you
ought to study the Russians and so I did
and I made a transition to a period in
which I paid great attention to Russia
and the Communist world I got a position
where I was responsible for running
programs to investigate Russia in the
Communist world I started writing about
it I took up the study of the Russian
language and I had a ringside seat for
the collapse of communism so when mal
Gorbachev came to power I followed his
doings very closely and when the Cold
War ended I was cast adrift I was left
somewhat at sea conceptually and I began
thinking at that point what is going to
replace the world that I've known what
will replace the world of the Cold War
what will be the most powerful defining
forces of the period after the Cold War
and after 10 years of thinking and
writing and reflecting and discussing
precisely that question the conclusions
to which I came are contained in this
book where were you from where's the
word it all start I'm a native
California i was born in oakland
california at the kaiser foundation
hospital which i believe is now regarded
as the first HMO in the united states
and I grew up in berkeley california
both my parents were academics both
connected with the University of
California my father was professor of
anthropology my mother was associated
with a program called the graduate
internship program and secondary
education which he was ultimately
director which was a program designed to
give people who wanted to teach and
secondary schools the credential to do
so without taking the required education
courses in the California school system
and my father what had an interest in
India his his field with South Asia he
was there many times the whole family
was there for a year so I had a kind of
international orientation from the
beginning and also an orientation toward
books toward scholarship and toward
teaching it was I guess natural for me
to gravitate to the study of
international affairs and to an academic
career what about school or were you
schooled well I I was educated in the
Berkeley public schools and then I did
my undergraduate work at Yale University
and then did postgraduate work at
Cambridge University in England and
Cambridge in England were very
influential because there I studied
history and that made me somebody who
sees the world in historical terms
although I am a political scientist by
trade I read a lot of history and
there's a good deal of history in this
book the first section of the book is a
kind of history of a modern world a
biography of the world in which we live
and those who take the trouble not only
to read the book but also to look at the
notes that the back will find many
references to prominent English
historians well after I finished at
Cambridge where I got a master's degree
I went on and
got a PhD at Harvard and have been an
academic ever since you say that in u.s.
foreign policy that the few the elite
must convince the shareholders to public
which way to go explain that foreign
policy is the preserve of the few in the
sense that most people don't have the
time or inclination to follow foreign
policy seriously and also in the sense
that we have after all a representative
government and so we assign to our
leaders the task of making policy but
because the United States is a democracy
that means that in order to launch any
large serious enterprise the government
has to persuade the public to support it
and that's not always easy to do it's
especially difficult throughout American
history when the country goes to war
it's always difficult to persuade the
American public to generate the kind of
support needed to pursue armed conflict
to the end it was true for George
Washington it was true for Abraham
Lincoln it's always been true now this
touches on one of the ways in which this
is a contrarian book i should say first
of all that although there's a good deal
about the united states this is not a
book exclusively or even mainly about
american foreign policy the united
states is the most important country in
the world in the 21st century and so
naturally i have a great deal to say
about it but what has triumphed in the
world i think is not so much the united
states or american power but these three
great ideas of which the united states
is a powerful proponent but certainly
not the only one and these ideas were
not invented in the united states
nonetheless american power is a very
important theme of the 21st century but
one of the ways in which this book is
contrarian is that i believe that
although for most of the rest of the
world in the first post Cold War decade
the great danger from the United States
seemed to be hyperactivity the danger
was that the United States would do too
much that it would throw its weight
around
in my view an equal problem an equal
potential danger over the medium and
long term is that the United States will
do too little will do even less in the
world than those countries that
criticize us want us to do and the
reason for that is precisely the point
to which you have alluded in order for
the United States to play any kind of
international role the American public
has to be persuaded that this is in
their interest it was easier to persuade
the American public to play an active
role in the world during the Cold War
because we were at war because there was
an enemy because many of the things that
the United States did could be portrayed
as acts of self defense and of course
Americans like other people are willing
to spend almost anything for the sake of
self-defense well there still is vast
scope for constructive American
involvement in the world in the
post-cold war world but the argument
that we have to do this to defend
ourselves is not quite so potent as it
was in the second half of the 20th
century you actually say that Americans
don't want to pay a lot for foreign
policy well in this sense Americans are
quite like everyone else nobody likes to
pay taxes nobody likes to pay for things
that don't seem immediately pertinent
the United States as I say was willing
to pay quite a lot for foreign policy
during the Cold War as long as what we
were paying for seemed to involve
self-defense but when paying involves
doing things that may be worthwhile but
don't affect us directly the public
balls the public is recalcitrant one
example I give in that book is the
humanitarian interventions in which the
United States engaged in the first pulse
post Cold War decade in Bosnia and
Somalia and Kosovo well most Americans
thought it was a good thing to stop the
killing and rescue beleaguered people in
these distant lands but when it came
actually to paying and especially paying
in the coin that's most important to
Americans namely American lives the
public wouldn't go along with it and
therefore these operations had to
conducted under the unstated premise
that the maximum number of allowable
American casualties for humanitarian
intervention was zero that is to say
Americans and I think we're like most
people in this in this respect are
willing to support good deeds the world
over but when it comes to paying and
especially paying serious costs we want
to be sure that there's something in it
for us early in the book you talk about
some places where you find yourself
right now and very familiar names in
foreign policy to Council on Foreign
Relations how do you relate to them well
the Council on Foreign Relations is a
private group devoted to the study of
foreign policy in the discussion of
foreign policy and it has a department
called the studies department which is a
mini think tank of which I am a member
and it was as a member of the studies
department that I developed some of the
ideas that go into this book I should
also say that the council was generous
in providing financial support so I
could take some time off from teaching
as was the Carnegie Corporation of New
York and the President of the Council on
Foreign Relations less gelb was quite
influential in shaping my idea about how
to go about writing this book he made
one very important suggestion he said to
me one day you know books about the
post-cold war world are really divided
into two groups their books about
foreign policy and their books about
economics you should try to write a book
that brings the two together and that is
one of the things that I've attempted to
do in this book and in the third of the
three main sections of the book I do
discuss how foreign policy and
international economics fit together in
the 21st century also another name on
the page is paul h nitsa School of
Advanced International Studies of the
johns hopkins university i teach at what
we call sise the School of Advanced
International Studies it's a graduate
school of international relations
located in Washington name for Paul
nitsa who is one of the cofounders the
other co-founder incidentally was
christian herter former governor of
suits and Secretary of State in the
Eisenhower administration and I have the
honor to hold the Christian a herder
chair in American foreign policy our
students are mainly masters students
it's a two-year course these are
students who have an interest in and
some background in international affairs
most of them in their mid-20s and they
go on to careers either in the
government or the private sector or the
nonprofit sector and they're terrific
students I enjoy teaching them many of
my D ideas were also formed in preparing
the courses that I teach and there's one
particular feature of my school that
bears on this book and it follows on the
point that I just made in our curriculum
we prescribe a heavy dose of
international economics and at the end
of the two-year course every student has
to pass an oral exam of an hour's length
half of it in a field such as American
foreign policy which I teach and the
other half in international economics so
I have sat in on what are now dozens I
suppose hundreds of hours of discussions
of international economics and from
those discussions I obtained an interest
in the subject but also a realization
that in order to present issues of
economics to a wider audience you have
to be very clear and so what I've tried
to do in this book is take what are
sometimes rather technical issues and
translate them into clear English prose
so that readers who are not specialists
can see how issues of trade and the
international monetary system fit into
our world of the 21st century do I
remember you saying in your book that
John Maynard Keynes was the greatest
economist in the 20th century John
Maynard Keynes was certainly the most
influential economist of the 20th
century and it was John Maynard Keynes
who made economists a kind of public
resource it was John Maynard Keynes who
married academic research and government
service and it was also Keynes whose
discoveries have been extremely
important for the management of
industrialized economies in the 20th
century we knew beginning in the 19th
century that economy
such as ours were subject to
fluctuations dips this was known as the
business cycle and in the 1930s we had
the steepest plunge of all the great
depression which had massive effects
both politically and economically it was
Keynes who proposed ideas about how to
prevent depressions not how to prevent
mild dips which we call recessions but
how to keep these downturns and he can
have economic activity from reaching
catastrophic deaths canes in this sense
may be said to have been one of the
saviors of capitalism it was Keynes who
put a floor under the market economy and
in the second half of the 20th century
in part because of Keynes's discoveries
in their application the market economy
went from strength to strength one of
the great themes of the second half of
the 20th century that I described in
this book is the contest between the
Communist planned economy and the free
market economy to see which one would be
superior in producing wealth well at the
end of the 20th century in the last
decade of the 20th century that contest
ended with a conclusive victory for the
free market and that may be the most
important event the most important
development of the second half of the
20th century with profound implications
for the 21st and for that development
John Maynard Keynes does there is a good
deal of credit ever in your life did you
think communism of work it was obvious
to anybody who visited the Communist
world as i did beginning in the 1970s
that it was a creaky inefficient system
and it was pretty obvious that it would
never overtake the united states and
japan and western europe in the
production of wealth that much i think
was clear but i never imagined the
communism would collapse as it did this
was one of the great developments and
really one of the most mysterious
developments in all of modern history
indeed I would say in all of history and
one of the questions that I address in
the first part of this book is how could
this have happened the collapse of
communism is an event that seems
more mysterious not less so as time goes
on it's especially mysterious especially
in need of explanation because although
the Cold War was in many ways similar to
the other great Wars of modern history
such as world wars 1 and 2 and although
its outcome had the same consequences it
completely changed the world the way it
ended was completely different it ended
without firing a shot it was not a
military decision so I asked myself how
could this have happened my answer was
and he is in the book that the cold war
was won not by the force of arms but by
the force of the Western example and
from that I go on to say that the power
of example is still operating in the
21st century the forces that destroyed
communism are still at large in the
world shaping the daily and long-term
activities of peoples and governments
everywhere and that is an extremely
important fact about our world probably
the name mentioned most in this book
from start to finish as Woodrow Wilson
why Woodrow Wilson was the 28th American
president and the book begins or at
least the first chapter begins with
Woodrow Wilson's appearance at Paris at
the end of World War two at the peace
conference convened there Woodrow Wilson
was important and is important for this
book because at Paris it was he who
first unveiled the ideas that conquered
the world it was he who first proposed
peace democracy and free markets as the
ideas that should guide and shape the
whole world these are ideas with which
we're all familiar and nobody would
think to deny or denounce them now but
they're really rather recent ideas as
human history goes and it was only
Woodrow Wilson who said the whole world
should be organized in this fashion well
the whole world was not organized in
this fashion for most of the 20th
century and yet with the collapse of
communism we find ourselves in something
like the world that Wilson imagine now
Woodrow Wilson has been and continues to
be an extremely controversial figure he
polarized his opinion some people see
him as
without honor whose advice if followed
could have avoided World War two others
see him as an incompetent short-sighted
blind politician whose lack of political
skills bungled the post-war settlement I
come out somewhere in between I think he
was a very poor politician especially
for somebody who'd risen to the top of
the American political system and yet
his vision is the one that has installed
itself as dominant in the world of the
21st century I compare Woodrow Wilson in
the book to Henry Ford he was to these
great ideas what Henry Ford was to the
automobile Henry Ford didn't invent the
automobile but he popularized it he
brought it to public attention and it
was Woodrow Wilson who although he
didn't invent these three great ideas
first put them on the international
agenda let me make one other point about
this comparison because there are a
number of comparisons and metaphors
throughout the book and that reflects an
important conviction of mine which
guided the writing of this book and that
is that serious books about politics and
history and economics and foreign policy
and this book covers all of them should
be works of literature written in vivid
lively and above all clear fashion and
not works of science written in
specialized language accessible only to
the very few so the reader of this book
will find lots of metaphors a few jokes
no jargon go back to the one the first
question I asked you I don't think you
answered was who did you write it for
who did you envision reading your book I
envisioned this book for people who are
interested in foreign policy who read
the newspaper who watched the news on
television and follow c-span and who
want to have a framework who want to
have a context for fitting together and
understanding all the issues that we see
every day before us so this is a book
for people who are knowledgeable
sophisticated and who are
interested in the big picture let me ask
you if I'm right about this i found you
to have the strongest views i mean i
didn't get your direct views very often
except on one issue and that was Poland
and the Czech Republic and Hungary being
a part of NATO you seem to be really
against that I do when that issue arose
I opposed it on the grounds that this
would be of no particular benefit to the
United States and would risk alienating
Russia and it did alien 8 Russia not
fatally so I have hopes that what I
regard as a mistake will be overcome but
the issue of NATO expansion in this book
is important in the context of the point
that I make in the second section of the
book the second section is called the
invention of peace and here I argue that
at the end of the Cold War the nations
of Europe and North America almost by
accident created something quite
unprecedented a new deeper more stable
more durable form of peace than the
world had ever seen I believe that we
have come up with a formula for peace
that I call common security and that is
in effect in Europe now although not in
the rest of the world and it's not
irreversible in Europe and my objection
to NATO expansion was that I feared that
it would interfere with and possibly
even destroy this new unprecedented and
desirable security system this security
system by the way owes a great deal to
the collaboration the rather unintended
collaboration I think of Mikhail
Gorbachev the last leader of the Soviet
Union and Ronald Reagan the president of
the United States for most of the 1980s
I say in the book that Mikhail Gorbachev
was the most deserving recipient of the
Nobel Peace Prize and I believe that
that's true i believe that he is a great
figure in history but i believe that
President Reagan deserves considerable
credit for helping to put in place this
system of common security the core of
which is a series of
limitation agreements over which
President Reagan presided and his
successor the first president Bush
followed in the late 1980s and early
1990s all right let's for just a moment
the president of the united states
george w bush picture book up spends the
weekend with it you know him from what
you've seen him do for the last couple
years what's he going to say about this
book where does it what does he read in
here that he doesn't like what does he
read in here that he likes based on what
you've seen him do in foreign policy
well this is a book about the last 200
years in the next 50 and it focuses
especially on the wide spectrum of
issues before us at the moment so i
would hope that the president or any
reader would find that he he got a
better sense for the context of the
issues with which he and all of us have
to deal i think the president would be
heartened by the optimism of this book
this is an optimistic book it's not
starry-eyed it's not Pollyanna sh it
certainly acknowledges that there are
serious problems in the world but it
does take the view that our ideas are
winning that history is on our side and
that optimism that sense that things are
going our way is I think an important
thing for a policymaker to know it gives
confidence I would hope and also suggest
that many of the policies that we
followed over the course of the 20th
century have been successful a reader of
this book including the president would
also i think be confirmed in the view
that of all the places on the planet the
middle east is the one most troublesome
to us there is a entire chapter devoted
to the middle east entitled well it's
it's drawn it's entitled the dragon's
lair and it's the title is drawn from
phrase in Latin that appeared on
medieval maps 2d mark the DMark aid and
denote places that were either unknown
or thought to be dangerous the phrase
was cave a hick drug honest
air here there are dragons and there are
dragons in the Middle East this is the
region from which emanates the most
serious threats to the United States and
the Western industrialized world weapons
of mass destruction terrorism and the
possibility of a cut off of our supplies
of energy so I think President Bush or
anybody reading this this book would be
confirmed in the view that the Middle
East requires some attention just how
one deals with this threat is of course
a matter of judgment but it is a place
that preoccupies us not only because it
is dangerous but also because the other
regions of the world that in the 20th
century were the most dangerous namely
Western Europe and East Asia are at
least for the moment relatively peaceful
freeing us to concentrate on the threats
emanating from the Middle East what how
do you relate from your own point of
view to the president's recent national
security directive where preemption is a
very important part of his philosophy
even preemption in the Middle East in
Iraq how do you come down on that based
on the Wilson triad the ville Sounion
triad peace democracy and free markets
will this work in the world but what I
think we can learn from this book about
the doctrine of preemption or preventive
war is that it is designed to address a
uniquely post Cold War problem if I can
go back for a moment the three most
controversial pronouncements or policies
of the Bush administration in its first
two years all had to do with one
particular problem the first of these
policies was a ballistic missile defense
the second the pronouncement of an evil
empire the third of them the doctrine of
preemption or preventive war all of them
are designed to deal with the problem of
nuclear proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction in the hands of the
so-called rogue state that is a country
that's violently anti-american and
anti-western and may not be deterred or
datura balazs the soviet union
was during the Cold War now this is a
particular post Cold War problem because
it didn't exist in the Cold War the end
of the Soviet Union solved many problems
but it also aggravated a few and this is
one of them during the Cold War the
countries we regard as rogues we're
clients of the Soviet Union and although
Moscow helped keep odious regimes and
power it also kept a linen it kept
control of them I don't believe that
North Korea or Iraq would be as close to
nuclear weapons as they seem to be if
the Soviet Union were still in business
and furthermore the collapse of the
Soviet Union presents an additional
danger where the proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction is concerned
precisely because all because of all of
the nuclear material in the former
Soviet Union that is now less closely
safeguarded than it was during the
Soviet period so what we see with this
doctrine and with these other policies
is an effort to come to terms with a new
and difficult and unfamiliar post Cold
War problem that's natural what the
ultimate solution will be we don't know
but we will debate it and we may try out
some of these policies so what we can
learn from the pot about the policies of
the Bush administration for on the basis
of what I've written is the importance
and the novelty of this problem all
right you're in the Oval Office of the
present he says dr. mana bomb are you a
PhD valley I do have a ph no yeah just
want to make sure there once in a while
that happens here that they're not what
should i do in Iraq what would you tell
him well it's a good question the
president has made the case as we are
discussing this that Iraq presents an
unacceptable threat and if it cannot be
disarmed through the United Nations then
it may well be necessary for the United
States actually to conduct military
operations to disarm Iraq I think that's
a powerful argument there are counter
arguments of course and here
the United States faces a trade off on
the one hand there are those who say you
shouldn't attack until the gun is
actually cocked and pointing at you
shouldn't attack until the threat is
imminent and that kind of attack is much
more compatible with international law
but that kind of attack is much more
difficult militarily even though it is
acceptable politically it's much easier
militarily to deal with a threat before
it becomes urgent it's much easier to
deal with Iraq before the gun is cocked
while Saddam Hussein is trying to obtain
the gun so that is militarily more
effective but politically more difficult
that's a trade-off that the president of
the United States gets paid to make I'm
glad that I'm not the one to make that
decision but I would say that the case
that he has made thus far seems to me to
be quite a powerful one on this
particular subject I do worry about two
things I worry about American support
for military operations should they
become costly and I worry about
continuing American support for the
occupation and reconstruction of Iraq
which I think would be necessary if and
when thought I was saying were removed
forcibly from power and in order to
reinforce American public support I
think some international support is
useful that is why I was glad to see the
president decide to go to the United
Nations for some kind of authorization
because I think United Nations
authorization could help firm up support
in the constituency that's most
important for any American military
operation or any American foreign policy
namely the American public and that of
course is a theme that emerges from this
book your background and where you're
associated now are all familiar names to
people who watch this network and if
this was a call-in show there'd be
somebody calling up and saying another
council on foreign relations guy a
one-world ER carnegie corporation paul
knit see Johns Hopkins all that
establishment names
and they would accuse you of being up to
something that they don't like and I
know you've heard these people talk
before from that point of view what do
you say to them when they have these
accusations about all these foreign
policy organization well of course these
organizations don't take official
positions on any issue and nobody told
me what I should write or what I
shouldn't write let me address the issue
of one world ism because there are those
who write about the affairs of the 21st
century who believe that the
nation-state is obsolete that it's
wearing away that international
organizations and non-state
you
the devil about the Americans who ask an
English Gardner how this country has
produced such wonderful lawns the secret
he replies is to quote get some good
grass and roll it every day for six
hundred years unquote well that story
illustrates yet another major theme of
the world in which we live we have
countries all over the world that are
trying to establish free markets and
many of them are trying to establish
working democracies I spend a lot of
time in this book discussing Russia and
China because I believe that in the 21st
century next to the United States they
are the two most important countries and
the great project for China is to
establish a working free market the
great project for Russia is to establish
a working free market and a working
democratic system why are they having so
much difficulty the answer I believe is
that in order to have free markets and
democracy you need not only the proper
values of the population but also
working institutions especially a
particular kind of government and one of
the things that we've learned since the
Cold War ended is that it turns out to
be more difficult to construct the
relevant and necessary institutions than
we ever imagined possible so it is the
struggle to construct these institutions
that we and the British have had
centuries to construct that preoccupies
most of the countries of the world and
in particular two of the most important
Russia and China earlier you talked
about Michael Crichton Japan's allegedly
devious and sinister approach to
international economics was the theme of
Rising Sun a best-selling novel by
michael crichton why mentioned Michael
Crichton did you read it by the way I
have read it and I've seen the movie and
I found them both entertaining but I do
not agree with the thesis underlying
both of them and I think that thesis has
been discredited the thesis was that
Japan had developed a new different and
more effective form of capitalism one
that departed from the classical
principles of free market organization
that come down to us from Adam Smith
through John Maynard Keynes this was in
the 1980s when Japan was grow
rapidly in the 1990s of course Japan has
experienced a pronounced and profound
recession and it is no longer thought
that the Japanese have invented a new
form of the market economy but the the
point there is that the principles of
the free market have triumphed although
they are to be found in different forms
Japanese capitalism is different from
American capitalism and Western European
capitalism is different from both one of
the great strengths of these ideas is
that the institutional forms they take
can differ so a country deciding that it
wants a free market economy can choose
from different models I compare the free
market here to General Motors which has
a complete product line of motorcars and
that's a strength it's a strength of
democracy as well because there are
different forms of democracy and this
versatility this lack of a single
obligatory model is one of the reasons
although not the only reason that these
institutions and these ideas have proved
so potent in chapter 5 you bring
Shakespeare into the book Romeo and
Juliet and West Side Story what's your
point West Side Story is a modern
version of Romeo and Juliet and by the
same token the chapter that that story
introduces deals with the security
problems of East Asia and there I argue
that the history of security and foreign
policy and international relations in
East Asia parallels the history of
security and foreign policy in Europe
although the same issues are transposed
to a different setting even as West Side
Story represents the basic plot of Romeo
and Juliet but transposed to a different
store it to a different setting and in
both cases the United States has played
a similar role the United States
continues to play a crucial role and the
prospects for peace for continued peace
in East Asia like the prospects for
continued peace in Western Europe Japan
not exclusively but to a very great
extent on the role of the
it states last one william butler yeats
you say a 2-line poem in the 1930s by
william butler yeats about charles
stewart parnell a hero of the struggle
for Irish independence made the point
that national independence does not
necessarily brings upward economic
mobility a lesson learned by millions of
inhabitants of countries once ruled by
imperial powers and you say then you
quote Barnell came down the road he said
to a cheering man quote Ireland shall
get her freedom and use still Breakstone
unquote point of that the point is to
respond to the very natural question if
peace democracy and free markets have
triumphed or at least if free markets of
triumph democracy has made great
progress and we now at least have a
model for peace why are there still
problems in the world why is there still
unhappiness wives they're still human
misery and my answer is that these ideas
even implemented perfectly cannot make
individuals happy that's a problem
that's a task for the individual the
great advantage of democracy and free
markets is that they remove some of the
long time oppressive structural
obstacles to happiness so I believe that
these systems and these ideas are better
for humankind not because they're a
magic formula for turning us all into
the happiest people we've ever seen but
rather because they help to remove some
of the traditional long-standing
obstacles the human fulfillment you say
and this goes with what we're dealing
with in the world today you say that in
the last four decades the 20th century
sixty leaders were killed through
terrorism why and is that more than in
history I don't know whether it's more
than in all of history and eyesight that
figure to make rather the opposite point
namely the terrorism did not begin on
September 11 2001 it has a very old
history goes back centuries even
millennia it was in some ways very early
in the nineteenth and twentieth
centuries it is in one sense more
dangerous in the 21st century because of
the availability or the potential
availability of weapons of mass
destruction
thinking here not so much of nuclear
weapons because I doubt that a terrorist
cell could obtain one although that's
not impossible but rather biological
weapons which could be used to great and
harmful effect by determined terrorists
so a terrorism is not something new it
is somewhat more dangerous now than it
was in the past but it's not going to it
is neither going to go away we will
never conquer terrorism absolutely nor I
believe is it going to shake the
dominance of these three great ideas I
say in the introduction that unlike
communism and fascism the terrorists of
September 11th have no chance of
controlling the world they do not
control nor do they have any prospect of
controlling a powerful nation state as
fascism and communism get their ideas do
not have universal appeal as communism
and fascism once did and unlike
communism and fascism which for a while
we're very successful in so far as the
ideas of the terrorists of September
11th have actually been put into
practice they failed in iran and
afghanistan so terrorism presents a
threat to the personal safety of
Americans but not to the structure of
the world of the 21st century you
dedicate this book right up here in the
front to an mandelbaum with love who is
she and mandolin and mantle vom is my
beloved wife and I could not have
written this book without her her love
and support were absolutely essential
but she made a further contribution she
edited the book she is a professional
editor of superb skill she went over it
twice and I strive in writing for
clarity and in striving for clarity and
for grace of expression her advice is
absolutely indispensable serabian Mary
we've been married now more than 25
years are there children we do not have
children in this book you mentioned
McDonald's what impact has McDonald's
had on foreign policy well I i use
mcdonald's as an example of the spread
of commercial and can
sumer culture and mcdonalds according to
some very interesting scholarship that's
been done on it is actually the bearer
of Western ideas especially in China it
is it has introduced to China the idea
of service which was not present which
has no role in a communist society and
it has also introduced the idea of
individualism parents take their
children in china to mcdonalds to
celebrate their birthday and that's a
very uncommon estai dia because in
communist societies celebrations and
holidays always celebrated the group so
in that sense I take McDonald's and
consumer culture as a whole as being one
of the forces that subverted communism
and won the Cold War and in the footnote
to which you refer I contrast McDonald's
with coca-cola which I say half
facetiously did not have the same
liberalizing impact in the 20th century
from the beginning of the end how many
countries became democracies I don't
know the exact number but it was an
extraordinary number at the beginning of
the 20th century there were only a
handful of democracies the United States
Great Britain a few in Western Europe
and some of Great Britain's dominions at
the end of the 20th century by the count
of Freedom House research organization
that keeps track of these things a
majority of countries were democratic or
democratizing that is a remarkable
record it's one that no one would have
predicted at the beginning of the 20th
century or in the years after World War
one or even in the 1970s it's an
enormous development and a powerful
testimony to the strength of these ideas
you have another book in mine I have
several in mind but I haven't made a
commitment yet of on the books you of
all the books you've written word would
you put this one in importance to you
well I think any author if asked what is
your most important book would always
say the most recent one but I believe
that this is my most important book
because it is the widest ranging it
takes on the biggest subjects and it is
accessible to the widest audience the
idea is that conquered
the world the name of this book our
guest has been Michael mandelbaum thank
you very much sir